mardi matin les élèves du collège
Jacques carartier à Issou sont retournés
en classe après 2 jours de retrait de
l'équipe enseignante la cause des
accusation de racisme et d'islamophobie
visant une professeur suite à la
présentation d'une peinture du 17e
siècle Diane et Actéon montrant des
Muses dénudés ces accusations avaient
suscité la crainte parmi les enseignants
de vivre une histoire similaire à celle
qui avait conduit à l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti en 2020 inquiète de la
situation oui parce que pu on en arrive
quand même à des
menaces qui font très peur après pour
mon fils je pas trop inquiète parce que
je le connais je sais que tout se passe
très bien mais bon c'est vrai que le
climat général il fait il fait un petit
peu peur le collège rencontre des
difficultés depuis plusieurs semaines
depuis le mois d'octobre selon nos
confrères du C8 actu 14 faits ont été
recensés contre trois sur l'année
scolaire précédente attente à la
laïicité à la sécurité ou encore
dégradation des biens il y avait un
problème de moyen qui se posait qui se
posait depuis longtemps et que c'est
vrai pour tous les établissements on a
vraiment besoin en ce moment de plus
d'adultes dans les établissements c'est
face à des situations
compliqué et on peut que les traiter
avec de l'humain le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'était rendu sur
place lundi 11 décembre pour apporter
son soutien au personnel éducatif et
souhaite plus de fermeté il faut qu'on
arrive à un système où il y a des
sanctions qui sont beaucoup plus
immédiates beaucoup plus fréquente ne
jamais attendre que la situation
s'aggrave pour convoquer un conseil de
discipline mais c'est tout de suite dès
les PR fait qu'il faut prendre des
sanctions et il y aura des sanctions le
ministre a annoncé que les élèves
avaient reconnu les faits dans le
collège des postes en renfort aux
équipes de vie scolaire seront mis en
place ainsi qu'une équipe académique
valeur de la République